firmado hace 20 años el tratado de
amistad buena vecindad y cooperación
entre argelia y españa que hasta ahora
regía el desarrollo de las relaciones
entre ambos países se basaba en ocho
principios generales entre ellos la
abstención de recurrir al uso de la
fuerza en sus relaciones bilaterales así
como el arreglo pacífico de
controversias para no poner en peligro
la seguridad internacional este anuncio
de argelia llega horas después de que el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez hablas en el congreso de los
diputados sobre la relación con
marruecos y volviera a defender la nueva
postura del gobierno más cercana a la
propuesta de autonomía de rabat frente a
la que pretende el sáhara occidental' de
autodeterminación como la mejor vía para
lograr la resolución del conflicto que
enfrenta desde hace décadas a rabat y
argel pedro sánchez sobre todo la
defendió como la mejor opción para
mantener la integridad territorial de
las dos ciudades autónomas españolas de
ceuta y melilla en territorio africano y
fronterizas con marruecos argelia señala
que justificando esta decisión se violan
las obligaciones legales morales y
políticas de españa frente al ter que
estuvo bajo su control entre 1958 y 1975
el frente polisario el brazo político
del sáhara occidental apoya la decisión
de argelia mientras que el gobierno
español lamentó la decisión pero asegura
que argelia es un país vecino y amigo y
dio el mensaje de tranquilidad ante el
cumplimiento de los contratos de
exportación de gas que hay entre argelia
y españa